let's go to our next caller from the 904
area code who's this all right David
this is Chris from Florida how are you
doing good how are you doing well this
is going to be a really this might be
kind of a downer question but I haven't
really seen it turn out there maybe the
husband and I'm not looking so I'm
sticking to it
do you think we kind of need to have
like another economic recession or
depression like I mean it looks like
we're already going that route even if
we weren't just with how everything is
now is now in this political landscape I
think we kind of need one and maybe
that's like really cynical of me but
what's your take on that what would be
the point of needing it like why would
we need an economic downturn or
recession well because I don't think a
lot of American people don't understand
how bad it is yet and it and I but it's
not a bad living of course if I may
mm-hmm if it's not bad yet then what do
you mean people understand how bad it is
yet are you saying that things are worse
than people realize so you think maybe
it would be good for them to get even
worse so people get it or I'm confused
yeah I guess sort of that because you
know you could throw numbers sure god no
I'm not sure that that makes sense right
because we want people to have an
accurate understanding of what's going I
D ly we would say this is what's going
on in the economy and there are some
indicators that don't bode super well
like one is usually there's always a
recession coming like at some point and
now it's been a while without one so
like that would be one piece of evidence
that one is coming I don't know exactly
when but at some point we're gonna have
one number two there are lots of people
including people like roughly my age
people who graduated college sometime
between oh six and twenty ten who
basically have been in the workforce
during a good economy right you can say
well it was a little better here a
little worse there it's gone up down
under Trump Obama but these have been
pretty good economies with with pretty
good unemployment rates and and so on
and so forth other than the wage issue
which of course is one they are complete
unprepared for what it's like when the
stock market is down 40% and you have
rising unemployment like there's a hole
almost like half a generation that
doesn't know what that's like
so would there be useful lessons in them
living through something like that
probably but I don't think that we
should be trying to convince people
things are worse than they actually are
I don't see the benefit of that well and
again just for perspective living in
North Florida like I just and I only
just graduated high school maybe two or
three years ago I was in college for a
little bit but now I'm working and I'm
taking some time off okay but just in
the last couple of years and I don't
know if it's just my area if it's just
like the Bible Belt of the US or how it
is okay I don't think I've seen more
homeless people like in my life then I
have just in like the last twenty two
three years oh okay yeah and and like I
don't think I've seen it to where all of
the jobs are now lower paying jobs and
and again that's something you can throw
out there like you do he will throw it
yes yeah I think I get the point which
is that sometimes the economy isn't so
good and when that's the case people
should know about it but as far as you
know homeland homelessness and wages and
low medium and high quality jobs those
are sort of other issues but I do
appreciate the call and I do wish you
the best in North Florida and it's all a
lot is going on there very very clearly
a lot going on in North Florida and with
Chris and and during that phone call
okay thanks to everybody who called in
today if you're still holding I
apologize that I didn't get to you we
can't always get to everyone but we will
take calls again